من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه ينضم الينا
مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل
نتابع معك المشهد بشقيها الانساني
والميداني نعم على المستوى الميداني منذ
صباح هذا اليوم وصل اربع شهداء الى مجمع
الشفاء الطبي جل هؤلاء الشهداء اصيبوا
بقناصه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في
المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه لمدينه غزه
والان بالتزامن مع هذا
في هذا الوقت دوي انفجارات لمدفع قوات
الاحتلال تطلق قذائفها بشكل عشوائي في
المناطق الشرقيه والمناطق الشماليه
الغربيه لمدينه غزه بشكل متواصل منذ مساء
امس وهذه الليله كانت الاعنف على مدينه
غزه بالتحديد قصف عنيف ومتواصل في المناطق
الجنوبيه الغربيه وافاد بعض المواطنون ان
قوات الاحتلال قصفت عدد من المنازل
الفارغه في تلك المنطقه يبدو ان قوات
الاحتلال تستهدف تلك المنازل سعيا في
التدمير المستمر والمتواصل في تلك المنطقه
وا سياسه جديده لاحداث اكبر دمار رغم
الدمار الكبير الذي حصل قبيل انسحاب هذه
القوات من المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه قبل
ايام لكن عادت من جديد باستهداف وقصف
مستمر وهناك عدد من المدارس التي تاوي
النازحين محاصره في المناطق الجنوبيه
الغربيه حتى هذه اللحظه لا نعرف مصير
النازحين في تلك المنطقه على الرغم من
وصول عدد من الاصابات من محيط تلك المنطقه
وعدد من الشهداء ايضا اما على اما على
المستوى الانساني فحتى هذه اللحظه لم
نشاهد ولم نلاحظ دخول اي من المساعدات الى
شمال قطاع غزه من المناطق الجنوبيه للقطاع
حتى هذه اللحظه ولا حتى قوافل الهلال
الاحمر التي تنقل الناز التي تنقل
الاصابات من شمال القطاع الى جنوب القطاع